hi everyone
oh hello oscar
how was your gaycation
that's very funny yeah
i thought of that like two seconds after
you left
hi angela
oscar
i have a question
would you like to join the party
planning committee the committee with
all the women
yeah because i'm gay
no
no
certain events have transpired
and i've thought about certain things
and i'm sorry for the way those certain
events transpired
and i would just like to make some
changes about certain things
and certain situations in certain
accounts right all right i'll join i'd
love to that's
thank you
thank you thank you
can i join too
never
hey you guys excited about the party
it's gonna be fun yeah
oh and look at you
showing your colors
bet you wish you wear a dress every day
what are you implying
all good happy halloween what happened
to all of those spooky decorations that
we had the cobwebs and such yeah i don't
know we put them all up last night
well you know what go buy some more i'll
approve the overages
sound good yeah good
oh yeah also about budget stuff
um
how many do you define like a
uh full employee salary plus benefits
like 50 grand
i'm gonna need you to find 50 grand in
the numbers
but we don't keep two sets of well
that's not what i'm saying just you know
find it pretend that your jobs depend on
it
well i looked through all the budgets
and there is one department yes that has
three people yeah doing the work that
could be done by two this is great
oh
yeah
oh
well i need to give my cat up for
adoption
the one who uses the doorbell or the one
with the mexican hat or the one with the
rain galoshes or the one that you let go
around naked angelus cats are cute
so cute that you just want to eat them
but you can't eat cats
you can't eat cats kevin
no the one with the long hair and the
denim pants comstock
okay look he's such a special kitty
you just want to find him a good home
[Music]
he loves those pants
i'll take him
please after the turtle i am enormously
proud of what i did for that turtle
oscar oscar will you take him no i'm a
dog person
if you pray enough you can change
yourself into a cat person those guys
always turn back angela action
so why would we
not what i think it is
good god
that one ugly cat is humping princess
lady no
awesome stop it mr ash bad cat that is
very bad you stop it right now i swear
he is fixed i know fixed that ain't
fixed no way no now listen you can't let
what you see here sully your image of
them they are good decent cats
i gotta go i'll be back in an hour
oh stop that oh the other one's watching
where is that bad cat oh you know who
you are excuse me petal i'm looking for
mr ash he's a bad cat bad bad cat you
hear me
you are bad no you look at
[Music]
this is getting weird
is she cleaning the cat with her tongue
oh
[Music]
has this been on the entire time i have
no idea
i was looking at
pictures of food on my computer
well sorry i'm late
i want to get that image out of my head
the psychological issues that go behind
licking a cat
are not things i want to go into
also i'm pretty sure she caused a pair
of ball thanks so much for coming thank
you so much
well
have we all calmed down yeah yes sorry
about that
it was all my fault
let's all try to do better next time
kevin great to see you yeah thank you
for the food oh and also
you suck
i beg your pardon you are like a
terrible person these guys care about
you and you're just
using them
again the food was very good
hey guys the christmas party is today
merry christmas everyone
no
is it i mean it says xmas party but i
think we all know what that's code for
so we're not gonna have a christmas
party this year
angela how could you do this to us oh
right like i'm responsible because i'm
in charge of the party planning
committee well you are the one in charge
don't blame me for something we all
forgot let's not blame her for something
we all forgot
i didn't realize how many of angela's
opinions i agreed with
until she tried to have my kneecap
shattered for sleeping with her husband
she makes a lot of very sound points
i knew the party was today but nobody
asked me to plan it so i didn't
funny how that works we're out there
sweating our balls off every day busting
our balls we deserve a christmas party
well then why don't we just get some
liquor and those mini cupcakes mini
cupcakes
as in the mini version of regular
cupcakes which is already a mini version
of cake honestly where does it end with
you people
angela had the baby
is it black because that would be
hilarious why
you know
would it be more hilarious than angela
having a chinese baby
a little bit yeah
right guys back me up
a little bit
oh did i win the pool uh no
right month wrong year
well no one won the pool angela wasn't
due for another month we should all go
to the hospital and visit her oh i'd
love to but um oh man i would but i
can't miss any more work well kevin and
i have to go because uh accounting has
its own little family yeah oscar's the
dad i'm oscar's dad and angela is my mom
why did you pack the apple snacks why
didn't you pack the apple snacks guys
because whenever i pack the bag you say
i do it wrong guys why don't you pack it
up guys
do you want to see a video of a weather
man who says bold front instead of cold
front it's insane not normal kevin can't
you see we're busy
philip needs his apple snacks seriously
kevin i'm just gonna have to go to the
store okay you go to the store
billability phillip it's all about
phillip i hate phillip
yes
kevin kevin oh you know my name well
that is shocking
kevin could you not do that what i'm
moving the ink down in my pen for work
here use my pen don't tell me what to do
shh
i don't need this and you obviously
don't need me kevin where are you going
away
tell philip that his stupid little baby
wish came true
hey kev how you doing buddy i can't hear
you
i'm giving you the silence treatment
how's it feel being ignored
okay i guess it's just that uh philip
got you something
yeah a 25 gift card itunes i think
there's like seven dollars left
it's just his way of saying thanks for
letting me hang out in accounting
phil got this from me sure
that was a really cool move all right
see you there bye phillip listen i high
five
yay
you